thanks to skillshare for supporting this
episode of journey to the microcosmos
the first 1000 people to click the link
in the description
to get a free trial of skillshare's
premium membership
[Music]
do you ever look at a microbe doing
something and think i wish i could do
that
i don't know maybe you don't maybe you
don't watch a vorticella casually grab
food from a distance and think wow i
wish i didn't have to get up to get a
snack
and maybe you don't watch a
single-celled out enter a protective
cyst and think
huh wouldn't it be neat if i could just
chill out in a bubble of my own making
when things get tough
and that's fine it's good to be content
with a human existence
it's got its perks we get to think about
things and
talk about things and make things and
for millennia
we've turned all of our thoughts and
conversations and creations
into culture and societies which have
helped us better understand the world
around us
whether through art or science we've
learned about
ourselves about the stars above us the
rocks below us and everything in between
and beyond
and that includes microbes we may not
have known about microbes until a few
centuries ago but that doesn't mean we
haven't made use of them before
whether that's the yeast we use to make
beer or the lactobacillus we use to
ferment milk
but apparently there is more to life
than food
and knowing that microbes exist has only
led to more questions about
how they exist which has only led to
more inspiration for how
we can exist counting up all of the ways
that scientists and engineers have been
looking to the microcosmos for
inspiration would be
an endless task so today we're going to
focus on one idea in particular
algae and the possibility that one day
algae will fuel our cars our airplanes
even our spaceships
algae is a very broad category that
roughly groups together
all aquatic photosynthetic organisms
whether they are
tiny cyanobacteria or a large piece of
kelp
but the algae we are most interested in
today are single-celled eukaryotes
like batreococcus bronie if you want to
find a living botrococcus
you can look in fresh and brackish
waters and if you want to find
fossilized botrococcus you can dig
through
precambrian oil shales where their
remains
point to another more remarkable fact
these tiny little algae
are the largest biological contributor
to crude oil in those shales now it
helps that when they're alive
somewhere between 25 to 75 percent of
dry weight can be made up of oils
so scientists have studied
bacteriococcus to see if we can
use the microalgae to make those
oils for us
[Music]
the search for a way to make biofuels
has taken on many
forms and many different places in the
1970s
the united states department of energy
started the aquatic species program
to explore the possibility of getting
algae to make fuels
of course the process is more involved
than just sitting back and letting algae
make oil for
us one microbe is just one microbe
their real power happens when they are
grown in large quantities
but algae do not come equipped with a
manual
on how to best grow them nor do they
tell you how to extract and refine the
oil they produce
scientists have had to unravel and
optimize those steps themselves
fortunately the simplicity of algae
makes them well suited for
experimentation but technology
isn't just the sum total of the research
that's made it possible
it's also the economics of how it fits
into the world
and algae have proven much more
challenging in that regard
in 2010 the estimated cost of a barrel
of algae-based fuel
was between hundred and twenty six
hundred dollars
while petroleum was just forty to eighty
dollars
many of the challenges that create that
discrepancy
are biological patriocus for example
grows too slowly to make it work for us
and other species and techniques
have had their own obstacles the aquatic
species program
ended in the mid-1990s and there have
been a number of companies that have
tried and failed
to bring algae-based biofuels to the
market but as is the case with so
much of science failure doesn't end a
story
it just becomes a part of another tale
the past few decades
have been marked by major advances in
the tools we use to study biology at the
molecular
and genetic level and those tools
are still always improving providing new
ways
to identify algae strains decipher their
genes
and engineer new pathways to maximize
biofuel production
and even if we never figure out
algae-based biofuels
we're still living in a world made all
the richer because of algae
because here's the thing about biology
we've come a long way and how we
understand it
but we are still really in our
infancy we are finger painting with
biology
while nature sketches and colors
masterpieces
that will always be eons ahead of us
but that does not mean we won't get
better
in fact we have to get better not just
for the sake of progress
but for the sake of our survival to make
things that won't just
improve our lives in the immediate
future
but will also leave our future selves
without
catastrophic problems we may figure out
biofuels one day but it will come with
new
questions and challenges about how they
are made
and how we consume human progress has
always demonstrated
both our ingenuity and our
short-sightedness
and the more we understand the
microcosmos the more
we will seek to use it but to use it
well
we have to understand how it fits into
the world that we have today
and the world that we want to exist
tomorrow
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us we'd like to also say
thank you again to skillshare for
supporting this video
earlier we mentioned using yeast to make
beer and along with many other things
this is a skill that you can learn on
skillshare the class
beer brewing basics hosted by justin
trazquez
is a course for beginners who want to
learn how to make and bottle their own
beer at home in this course justin will
walk you through the brewing process
to help you make a simple ipa from a
pre-measured beer brewing kit
it's beer but it's also science
skillshare is an
online learning community that offers
membership with meaning
with so much to explore real-world
projects to create and the support of
fellow creatives
skillshare empowers you to accomplish
real growth
it's curated specifically for learning
meaning there aren't
no ads to distract you and they're
always launching new premium classes
so you can stay focused and follow
wherever your creativity takes you
a premium membership will give you
unlimited access so you can join the
classes and communities
that are right for you and an annual
subscription to skillshare is less than
ten dollars a month
if you're one of the first thousand
people to click the link in the
description
you can get a free trial of skillshare's
premium membership
we also wanted to let you know that we
have some new journey to the micro
cosmos
merchandise available at dftba.com
we have this new brachialis pin as well
as these paramecium
socks and final thank you goes to all
the people whose names are on the screen
right now these are our patreon patrons
the people who made it possible for us
to return for our fourth
season of journey to the micro cosmos if
you like what we do here
and you'd like to help us continue to do
more of it head on over to patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss
check out jam and germs on instagram and
if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]